you know there's stages of red pill and
the first stage of red pill is really
realizing that women are not up to par
these are what the women our
grandmothers and mothers and mothers
were raised to do and did and we were
not taught any of that my generation was
just left a muck okay and then you start
to realize that this sing is just crazy
and what I realized is women are really
sensitive to aging whenever I tweet
anything about women looking uglier yes
at an older age all of the women lose
their minds now I want to I want to tell
you what started this thought I had a
tweet earlier this week talking about
how no at 35 you cannot compete with 22y
olds and the reason I had that thought
was I looked at the most beautiful
35-year-old women that I know and I
thought to myself okay there their skin
still sags they still got light wrinkles
or they got a Botox forehead either or
you know whatever pick your poison um
they have fake whitened teeth like they
they've they've or maybe a fake BBL
whatever money they've put into staying
attractive I I don't care I'm not even
hating on it but my point is they spend
all of this money fake
boobs the gym
whatever only to not be able to compete
with a 22-year-old because I could go to
a college camp campus and find women
hotter and it wouldn't be hard it would
be like half of the campus um then what
they'll do is they is you see these
copes you see these like copes like
they're like ah not the younger women
and they'll and there's a couple copes
that I really see so cope number one
well these women are than
me really Rebecca you've had 15 years
and you think the 22 year-old's done
more
damage well yeah yeah
but it's the new generation and I'm like
well who raised that
generation I okay so first it's them
trying to discredit their purity so
they'll be like oh well they're
okay then they'll say well you
know I look better than them and I'm
like
really really do
you and it's like okay guys there's
exception there's JLo okay JLo is really
hot but are you JLo really like why as
women do we have the sensitivity to
aging it's okay it doesn't have to be
the end of the world and I really just
had this series of tweets where I talked
about this by your 30s like you're not
supposed to be sexy anymore yes I said
it I said it shoot the messenger I don't
care I don't care shoot the messenger
because by your 30s you're supposed to
have developed wait for it guys
character yes yes yes and you know looks
and looking sexy and all that guys it
just looks kind of sad in your 30s it's
sad like this is delusion like it's
just it's embarrassing imagine being a
wife and a mother and all these women
will tweet tweet me their selfies like
please stop put it away I don't want to
see it and and they're these only fans
these old only fans models are tweeting
at me their nudes and this is just
exhausting and tiring so I see a couple
copes cope number one is well the
younger women are cope number
two is well the younger women are fatter
well I'm in better shape than these
young
women and the men will still pick them
over you sorry sorry and then three is
well I have a better my personality is
so much better is
it is it really
can we
just and what does that go back to
narcissism yes I am so special and
amazing and I need to argue with pearl
that I am hotter than the 22y olds 25
year olds I just need to prove Pearl
wrong and then what do they do they call
Pearl ugly oh well Pearl you look
old
and and and I would say the 22y olds are
hotter you know calling me ugly doesn't
make you any Diane and this is the thing
these old women it's just like and and I
think to myself wow these are wives and
mothers that raised us these are the
wives and mothers that will raise the
next generation of children dear God I
this is why I think that some women
should not have children because can you
imagine having that level of
narcissism can you imagine being so
narcissistic that you can you cannot
read a tweet about younger women being
hotter without taking it personally and
crying to me about it wow Pearl you are
just the meanest where you know I just
think it's better that we live in
reality and understand that we age and
as we age we will be valued for
different things um really in the world
unfortunately the number one agent that
we have is beauty you will make the most
money off of beauty and you will get the
highest Suitor off of beauty character
does not compete with beauty I don't say
this with a happy heart I I don't I
don't say this because I'm happy about
it but it's just reality men are looks
first looks is where it starts and the
22y olds are going to have you beat
sorry sorry like please stop whining to
me about this okay so then I get the
copes and I realize that men are they
are assistant they assist in this
delusion and how do they assist they say
hey and I realize that men do this so
they can get sex and I'll give you an
example I've noticed that broke men are
always the ones that'll say oh well I
like them
thick do
you do you I mean there's a difference
between thick and
obese all right there there's a
difference there there's a right I I
understand there might be a little curvy
a little less curvy but let's be honest
let's just I you don't see any Rich
handsome
men with anything but women with small
wastes oh shoot the messenger ah Pearl's
so mean Pearl's the
mean and the reason that I say this is
not because this is the next coat Pearl
is just so miserable and she's just so
I just cry myself to sleep every
night really and I do this because I'm
just really sick of seeing pandering I
am sick of seeing the media the
marketing I am sicking I am I am sick of
seeing the right and the left Pander so
I had another tweet and this one really
hit people where it hurts and instead of
asking is it true what do the women do
they attack you girl Pearl the big
meanie so I tweeted I said no your
husband doesn't have husband goggles he
notices you aging sing is an epidemic
now what did I mean by this now number
one is this true or is it
false wait for it crickets does do
husbands notice that women
age yeah and I noticed I had I'll tell
you what made me think of this
phenomenon I noticed that when men
showed pictures of their wives to me it
was always a picture from like 10 years
ago they notice you know and this
doesn't mean this does not mean that men
will leave you high and dry that they
cannot love you for different things
this does not mean you are worthless if
you age but what it does mean is husband
goggles are not real
it's just a thing that men say to make
women feel better about getting old now
and what do I what do I mean by Sing
Sing is telling women what we want to
hear so we can live in delusion for a
lifetime um and another thing that made
me think of this
was I've heard of cases of um let's just
say guys as they get into their 60s or
70s you know having erectile dysfunction
right and really they're just not
attracted to their wives like they used
to be because they're getting older
right it's one thing to have a 30-some
year old wife but this idea that if you
marry your husband at 25 that he is not
going to notice that you aged by 65 is
just delusion it's just not true this
isn't to hate on marriage this isn't me
being mean but this is just me saying it
would be good for us to live in reality
looks aren't everything and the second
half of your life as women character is
the most important thing because nobody
is that hot over 35 all right if you
want to extend it and make it 40 so be
it but the point of the matter is there
is a cut off for looks as women I see
the most beautiful women on the planet
from 2030 40 years ago that look crazy
now an example of this is Madonna she
was was a beautiful world-renowned pop
star Britney Spears is another one now
are they really hot sexy no they keep
taking off their clothes and it is sad
and depressing and I am depressed that
the level of wives and mothers on the
market right now are really just selling
us these dreams so now mind you I don't
know much about this chick so when I use
these people as examples I don't know
anything about their lives they very
well could be amazing awesome people
don't know but what I point out is I
typically can tell a lot by a chick by
how she reacts to being told she is not
the hottest thing since sliced bread I
think this chick was one of them when I
tweeted that at 25 you are hotter than
35 and she just really needed to show me
her selfies wow that is exactly what I
needed a post wall women selfies thank
you now she says Pearl is upset that
she's aging out of the system she
insists leads to happiness and because
she is miserable and alone so there we
go Attack
One you she didn't say you're wrong she
said you are miserable and
alone oh yes I just
cry every night in my misery she wants
happily married couples to be miserable
too oh how did you know no
Sarah how did you know all right it's
not sing it's called being in love she
has clearly never experienced and is
likely to ever experience with that
insufferable attitude she is a cancer so
I have I'm just going to take my notes
of this super happy wife and mother I
think you know seems very happy
um sorry and so she said you are
upset
you are I mean she says aging out so
just you know old and
ugly
whatever um you want us to be
miserable um
you will never you'll be alone forever
and you're a
cancer where is the she is
wrong
where where is it am I
wrong why like I just cannot take this
simpery I cannot take this outrage when
they never answer the question am I
wrong now it's you know Pearl is just
this ugly chick never attacking what I
said or the argument which really if you
listen to I had about like 50 tweets on
this I'm just a tweeter it's so easy
it's like you can just pull one I had
like 50 tweets on this where I explained
that you're not supposed to be hot in
your 30s because it is about
character yes it is very sad when these
wives and mothers are clutching on to
their youth that they no longer have and
and trying to be these hot young chicks
that they're just not anymore you're
supposed to evolve and just become you
know the grandma that's like baking
cookies and stuff they used to know this
you know and there's a reason I didn't
come up with these terms guys a lot of
the stuff like leftover women old made
like this wasn't me these have been
common terms in all of
history Pearl isn't what guys want she's
tall not feminine masculine logical
argumentative
controlling um for her to find love she
needs a robot dude like
her so it's just back to the personal
attacks personal attacks personal
attacks you know I I thought this was a
Marketplace of ideas and what you'll see
from the conservative Christians a lot
is they attack me personally why why is
what I am saying Incorrect and that's
what we have to default to what is truth
what is real not oh boohoo Pearl pointed
out that you get old do you know how
many messages I get from happily married
wives and it warms my heart because
women that are happily married are not
concerned about what the internet thinks
what Pearl thinks and they are certainly
only concerned about what their husband
thinks and they know that they age they
know that they get older but they are
focused on character and those wives
typically know their husbands like the
back of their hand they know it doesn't
matter if a younger chick is is hotter
because I know my husband so well they
could never compete they have spent
their lives becoming amazing phenomenal
wives and they do exist and they are out
there and most of them I hate to break
it to you agree with me yes yes and it's
unfortunate because the women that go on
social media talking about how amazing
of a wife they are typically aren't the
ideal like typ and guys there's
exceptions I could point to you
exceptions but
the issue is and why aren't they the
ideal because what is the number what is
one of the best traits of a wife
humility humility wait for it humility
you are not the best thing since sliced
bread and they know I pointed out on my
show yesterday that
when that when the feminist answered the
question about
traditionalism she was very arrogant
where the housewife answers the question
about
traditionalism and she says I always try
to put my husband's needs first and the
way you answer questions is really I
don't know you can just there's just
something you can see about women that
just have humility they know they're not
perfect they know they're not amazing
but they do the best that they can and
they're not busy tweeting their selfies
at me all right like this is just great
like please and and I wanted to point
out one thing just to make myself clear
no no no this is not me attacking
marriage no this is not me saying that
your husband will not love you for
different things my whole point is that
I think that we should live in reality
with the fact that we age and stop
crying about the fact that we age and
make up all these words to make us feel
better about aging now you get uglier
the older you get and that's okay
because you can have better character
for your family and loved
ones wow